Okay.
Let's take some phone calls at (617) 830-4750
and see what's on people's minds.
Um, why don't we start today with our color
from the two five two area code.
Who's calling today from two five two?
Yeah.
Hey, how you doing?
You said your name is Keenan?
No, GI.
Deon.
Okay, good.
Yeah, this is awesome.
Oh, so, um, my question to you is, well, um,
so I'm in, this was a while ago, but Donald
Trump, common stuff, a nationalists and I
know you stay, you didn't agree with, um,
um, nationalism.
I don't want to throw me in you, but I know
you said that there was not, um, you, you,
you call yourself a patriot and a nationalist.
And my question to you is like, um, I know
there's different forums and nationalism and
I think that this is one of those things that
do not want the right to have a monopoly on.
Sure.
Cause I know there's liberal nationalism and
civic nationalism and nationalism has a very
complicated history.
So will you reconsider like the, the, the,
um, like would you reconsider, um, like civic
nationalism or the white nationalism?
Listen, I don't remember saying I'm a patriot,
not a nationalist.
I think I remember saying there's a difference
between patriotism and nationalism.
I'd have to go back and listen, listen to
the clip.
Here's my thing.
Here's your, you're pointing out very astutely.
The problem with a lot of these political
labels.
So for me the problem is not the idea of nationalism
per se in some kind of, uh, um, you know,
a morphous or hypothetical sense.
It's that very often what the American, right,
which as you say has, has done a pretty good
job of monopolizing the term nationalism and
patriotism.
What they mean by that is a very particular,
we're better than other countries.
Our people are better.
We know everything.
We have the best system, the idea that we
should look to Europe for what to do on healthcare
or to whatever.
They're against that and that I have a problem
with now if nationalism were rebranded as
hey, you know what, we are going to design
the best cities that reduce structural, uh,
segregation, allowing along racial and economic
lines and we are going to take pride in the
fact that we have a modernized, our public
transit system is such that it's the envy
of the world.
Those are things that for me are more logical
to be sort of nationalistic about.
So I agree with you.
I would love to sort of take back control
of the concept of nationalism but the term
itself has been pretty tainted at this point
to mean a particular reactionary thing.
Yeah, I've been thinking over the past few
months about certain things.
I know like time says, I know that there's
generally has, how has he tore his like nationalism.
There are certain things that the left palm,
Dang, I forgot a few of the terms up here.
The thing.
But, um, I know there is a few things that
the left has a allergy tours and don't get
me wrong, I understand because of the history,
but like, like, you know, I'm just starting
to think more carefully about these things
and I'm like, well, I mean, yes, you know,
mass numbers of you, you know, the, there
was two world wars, they devastated Europe
because the mansion is nationalism and actually
antisemitic the brands.
We're getting into something a little bit
different t on.
I, I appreciate the call.
I'm gonna let you go.
It's a very, very good topic and I'm glad
that you are thinking about these issues so
deeply.
That's a very, very good thing.